je vous demande d'applaudir geoffrey
cousin bonjour à tous donc je vais être
au théâtre avec vous je fais partie des
bizuths de l'équipe
donc c'est la première fois que je parle
devant autant de personnes je suis
vraiment très c'est vraiment très
délicat
donc moi je vais ce soir je vais vous
parler de temps tout simplement donc le
temps c'est quoi le temps c'est une
valeur une vraie valeur qui nous permet
d'agir et de comprendre le changement
mais quand on parle de temps si on parle
du monde de demain il faut déjà
comprendre son passé son présent et son
futur
alors qu'est ce que nous apprend
l'histoire l'histoire nous apprend
quelque chose de très important sur le
monde que nous connaissons actuellement
tous les cinq cent cinquante ans un
nouveau paradigme secret le paradigme
c'est quoi c'est l'ensemble des
structures que vous connaissez dans
votre environnement
pour simplifier
un paradigme secret enfin un paradigme
s'annonce via quatre coupage ou rupture
aujourd'hui on vit quatre rupture
majeure
la première rupture elle est écologique
on a consommé 80% des ressources non
renouvelables de la planète
plus aucun accord n'est possible avec la
planète
on est dans une phase de non retour
la deuxième rupture et technologique on
passe d'un monde mécanique à un monde
numérique
aujourd'hui on parle en réseau tous les
réseaux sont concentrés dans un espace
global mais on parle aussi de rupture
philosophique et qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une rupture philosophique c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les hommes vous vous
commencez à comprendre que le bien-être
le bonheur n'est pas dû à une
circonstance une conséquence on
l'appelle comme on veut
externe mais bien à une prise de
conscience interne et enfin on parle
rupture économique on passe du de la
consommation massive de la possession à
la création à l'envi de création mais on
passe aussi à l'individu à l'individuel
au collaboratif
donc il faut pas avoir peur de ce
changement de paradigme
on est dedans le dernier paradigme
c'était à la renaissance et on appelait
ça la modernité
aujourd'hui on tourne une page de ce
monde et on est dans une nouvelle
dynamique paradis cmic alors nous
citoyens on a plusieurs choix parce que
quand un changement s'annonce
la plupart du temps que fait l'être
humain ils s'opposent à ce changement
ou pire quand le changement est
nécessaire d'être humain reste campé sur
ses positions nous
citoyens on a besoin aujourd'hui d'agir
en faveur et d'accueillir ce nouveau
paradigme
alors moi je suis pas speaker je vous
témoigner une expérience ma dernière
expérience et une de mes plus belles
expériences
on s'est posé la question comment
changer le monde dans lequel on vit
comment avoir un impact positif dans ce
monde et on s'est dit qu'elle est la
valeur la plus précieuse qu'on peut
avoir sur cette planète et la réponse
est venue naturellement
la valeur la plus précieuse qu'on
possède aujourd'hui c'est notre temps ce
n'est pas l'argent ce n'est pas
l'énergie
c'est notre temps rien ne remplace le
temps alors on a décidé quelque chose on
a décidé d'accorder 0,42 % de notre
temps pour un but durable pour des
choses positif 0 42 % de notre temps
ça contribue à trois heures de temps par
mois alors vous savez
ce qu'on a fait avec 0,42 % de notre
temps avec 0 42 % de notre temps on a
construit un supermarché
le truc le moins glamour qui existent en
france je le supermarché
c'est une des plus belles expériences de
ma vie alors je vais vous exposer
aujourd'hui quelles sont les
conséquences de ce supermarché avec 00
42 % de notre temps on s'est réunis et
on a bûché sur des problématiques qu'on
maîtrisait pas forcément on a travaillé
sur tout ce qui nous tous qui nous tout
ce qu'on pensait être néfaste pour notre
environnement
alors on a posé ça sur papier et on
s'est dit qu'est ce qui est néfaste pour
l'environnement aujourd'hui la pollution
les inégalités le long le non accès à
l'alimentation de qualité ont été
indignés de savoir qu'une mère de
famille célibataire il ya une patte de
1000 euros par mois est incapable de se
payer des produits bio au quotidien donc
concrètement ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que plus de 80% des gens ne
peuvent pas se nourrir convenablement et
pour moi se nourrir convenablement
c'est pas manger
et pizzas et je citerai pas la marque
c'est manger des produits de qualité
alors on a essayé de comprendre pourquoi
ces produits coûté aussi cher
pourquoi et là on s'est rendu compte de
plein de choses on s'est rendu compte
qu'il y avait des monopoles dans la
distribution
je pense qu'on était un petit peu trop
innocent juste avant alors on s'est dit
qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire dans
notre supermarché et là on a commencé à
rêver
et ça a fonctionné la communauté
et nous donne 0 42% de son temps qui
nous permet à nous enfin nous à la
communauté d'agir pour son
concitoyens en donnant à 0 42 % de notre
temps on peut réduire les frais de
fonctionnement de n'importe quelle
structure n'importe laquelle
alors on s'est dit bah si on n'a pas
beaucoup de frais de structure
on va afficher les marges les plus
basses du marché et c'est ce qu'on a
fait dans notre supermarché vous trouver
des produits bio accessible à tous
globalement aujourd'hui en donnant 0,42
pour cent de votre temps dans un premier
temps vous pouvez vous nourrir
convenablement mais on s'est dit mais en
plus de ça nous c'est 0 42% notre temps
donc c'est pas notre travail c'est pas
note sais pas c'est pas notre métier on
fait ça on se réunit on aime bien et
généralement on dépense plus que 0 42 %
de notre temps puisque quand on se
réunit on fait la fête on parle on rêve
donc ça dure bien plus longtemps et là
on s'est dit mais qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire d'autre avec ses 0,42 % qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire d'autre parce que même
en mains en ayant la marge la plus basse
du marché
on arrive quand même à faire des
bénéfices alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire
de ses bénéfices je crois qu'on est le
seul supermarché au monde à se poser
cette question
sincèrement et là on a commencé à
arriver encore et encore et encore donc
on a réuni les les agriculteurs voient
aujourd'hui on travaille avec plus de 90
des agriculteurs locaux et on les a
réunis et héros et on a on a commencé à
parler avec eux est hélas à émerger et
on a entendu des choses magnifiques de
la bouche des des agriculteurs on parle
de robotique dans l'agriculture
on parle d'eux
robotique dans l'agriculture mais nous
ça nous parle aussi donc on s'est dit en
plus de rendre accessible la nourriture
biologique à tout le monde
on va pouvoir réinvestir ses bénéfices
aux côtés des producteurs pour les aider
à développer encore plus d'agriculture
biologique et favoriser la transition
écologique de notre territoire et on a
encore continuer à rêver et on s'est dit
bon qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire
d'autre avec ses bénéfices et là on a eu
un rêve
on s'est dit si on dégager une autre
partie des bénéfices qu'on rénove et des
corps de ferme qu'on réinsérer des
personnes en extrême précarité et qu'en
plus de ça ont racheté leur production
et là tout le monde a commencé à pleurer
c'était la fin mais on l'a fait on l'a
fait donc ce que je vous amène moi ce
soir
à travers ce talk ce que je veux vous
communiquer comme message c'est
simplement demain papa demain demain
repéré à autre chose qui vous repérez la
chose qui vous tient le plus à coeur
quelle action vous avez envie de
défendre aujourd'hui les abeilles sont
en péril des gens sont à la rue la
planète est matraqué vous êtes tous
responsables dans cette salle et moi
aussi
mais ce n'est pas définitif
alors ce que je vous demande c'est dès
demain accordé 0 42% à une tâche qui
vous tient à coeur
si chaque
des français capables de de 0,42 % de
leur temps
le donner chaque année on pourrait
accorder deux milliards cent soixante
millions d'heures en france pour des
actions de développement durable
merci à vous tous
[Applaudissements]